jusque là pas beaucoup voilà pas trop
pâtir
juste ça soit pas très chic ça y est le
petit pinceau maintenant c'est jouer et
regarder même shota pas très bien mais
c'est vrai je vous feriez un très beau
cocu bien cyrille nouvelle star de la
télé vous prenez jamais de drogue
non je vais jamais d'alcool baiser pas
souvent quel est l'intérêt de faire tout
ça est battu vous dire c'est pouvoir
inviter thierry ardisson d'hautmont et
monsieur j'aurais bien les négocier
pendant des mois avec dorothée pour
qu'elle accepte de venir en lisant tu
vas voir ça va être super arme est
gentil où elle était premier degré en
colère proviendrait était vraiment fâché
soi disant a été contente de mouiller
mais le problème c'est que les gens
soient si notre vie était à refaire vous
changeriez quoi alors je dois répondre
ouais je verrai plus mes enfants j'ai
tellement sacrifiait je vais pas
beaucoup
et si c'était à refaire je passerai
quand même plus de temps avec eux
maintenant je les voie plus
quand j'étais petit je voulais pas
beaucoup à 20 ans lorsque vous arrivez à
paris lui travaillé chez arte puis chez
radio nova
aujourd'hui vous chantez et quand il
pète et le trou son slip à quel moment
vous avez pris la mauvaise décision
[Rires]
répondait à aucun moment naturellement
ça me semble est une suite logique on
peut écouter radio nova en pétant et en
trouant son slip concert la liberté
[Musique]